THOUGH TO THINK THAT WITH ALL
THOSE QUESTIONS RED FLAGS
CONCERNS. YOU'RE RIGHT WILL
FULLER ENDS UP WITH MORE
MONEY THAN JUJU SMITH
SCHUSTER, BUT THAT'S WHAT
HAVING THE ABILITY
TCH
IT IS SENSE BRINGS BIG PLAYS
AND THAT'S WHY DESEAN
JACKSON IS FINDING ANOTHER
HOME. DESPITE ALL THESE YEARS
IN THE NFL. THIS WILL BE
SEASON NUMBER FOURTEEN. HE'S
34 YEARS OLD, BUT HE'S GOT A
ONE-YEAR DEAL TO GO BACK
HOME TO SOUTHERN, CALIFORNIA.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING ON THE EAST
COAST HIS ENTIRE NFL CAREER.
HE PLAYED COLLEGE FOOTBALL AT
CAL BERKELEY. AND NOW THE
RAMS ANNOUNCED LAST NIGHT
DESEAN JACKSON BRINGING THAT
ELEMENT TO LA FOR A YEAR. YOU
GOT ROBERT WOODS. YOU GOT
ROBERT WOODS, YOU GOT COOPER
CUP EVERYTHING'S TAKEN CARE
OF UNDERNEATH. NOW YOU GOT
THAT GUY WHO IS HEALTHY CAN
STRETCH THE FIELD AND GIVE
MATTHEW STAFFORD A LONG DOWN
THE FIELD TARGET. THE PROBLEM
IS GUYS PLAYED 8 GAMES OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS. YEAH.
THAT'S THE BIG THING. I MEAN,
IT'S LIKE FULLER, YOU KNOW.
RECEIVERS LIKE THIS, YOU KNOW
TO ALWAYS MAKE THE COMPARISON,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE CHEETAHS
RIGHT THERE THERE CHEETAHS IN
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE HIGH
OCTANE BIG SPEED, YOU KNOW,
THAT THEY'RE HIGH OCTANE BIG
SPEED, YOU KNOW, BUT IF THEY
PULL THE SLIGHTEST MUSCLE
IT'S LIKE WHOA, OKAY, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN'T GET OUT THERE
AND CHASE GAZELLES TODAY. I
MEAN, THAT'S THAT'S HOW IT
THIS IS LIKE SPECIAL SPECIAL
SPECIMENS AND DESEAN JACKSON
AND YEAH, HE'S BEEN BANGED UP
BUT MAN IF HE'S HEALTHY, HOLY
CRAPOLA. WILL THAT BE FUN TO
WITH THE RAMS, YOU KNOW FIRST
OFF HE'S GOT TO BE SO HAPPY
TO GOING BACK TO CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN AROUND TO SEAN A
LITTLE BIT AND I THINK THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN ON HIS RADAR BUT
TO GO THERE AND YOU MENTIONED
IT WITH COOPER CUP AND WOODS
WHO COULD DO ALL YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT LIKE WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT WITH WITH WOLF
OR THEY COULD DO ALL THE 15
TO 20 TO 25 AND TO FIVE YARDS
AND ALL THAT TYPE OF STUFF.
BUT NOW YOU GOT MATT STAFFORD
COMING OUT ON THE EDGE AND
IT'S YOU KNOW, A LITTLE PLAY
BOOTLEG FAKE TO THE RIGHT AND
NOW HE'S ROLLING TO THE LEFT
AND HE'S GOT WOODS IN THE
FLAT AND COOPER CUP COMING
OVER THE MIDDLE. AND USUALLY
THEY RUN LIKE THE OUTSIDE GUY
LIKE A DESEAN JACKSON ON THE
20-YARD COME BACK. OH NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THEM
FAKE THE 20-YARD COME BACK.
GO 60 YARDS DOWN THE FIELD
FAKE THE 20-YARD COME BACK
POST IT OVER THE MIDDLE 50
YARDS DOWN THE FIELD AND THEY
GOT A QUARTERBACK WHO'S GOT A
FLAMETHROWER FOR AN ARM AND
THAT'S GOING TO WORK YOU TALK
ABOUT THEM BEING ABLE TO
STRETCH THE WHOLE FIELD AND
MAKE YOU DEFEND THE WHOLE
FIELD AND MAKE YOU DEFEND THE
WHOLE FIELD THAT WAY. THAT'S
WHERE THEY COULD BE.
GARY WAS STAFFORD. DESEAN
JACKSON THOSE RECEIVERS YOU
MENTIONED AND WE KNOW
MCVEIGH'S GOING TO RUN THE
BALL. I MEAN, IT MAKES SENSE
IF HEALTHY STAY HEALTHY,
RIGHT IF HEALTHY AND REALLY
THE THREE GAMES HE PLAYED IN
2019 THE LAST LIKE IT WAS
WEEK ONE. HE WAS SPECTACULAR
TOO LONG TOUCHDOWN PASSES AS
THE EAGLES RACE 217. NOTHING
DEFICIT AGAINST WASHINGTON
RIGHT WEEK TO IT WAS IN
ATLANTA MONDAY NIGHT GAME. I
BELIEVE BARELY PLAYED SUNDAY
NIGHT GAME BARELY PLAYED
RIGHT? THAT'S WHEN HE STARTED
TO HAVE SOMETHING GROIN
HERNIAS.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, THEN
CAME BACK LATE IN THE YEAR
FOR JUST LATER IN THE YEAR
FOR JUST LIKE A QUICK LITTLE
NAP TIME. SO IT WAS ONE GAME
THAT YEAR. YEAH GREAT, BUT IT
WAS A FUN GAME AND THAT ONE
GAME CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
FOR A TEAM, BUT I JUST IT'LL
BE INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
MUCH YEAH THE FACT THAT IT'S
BEEN ABOUT 12 HOURS AND I
DON'T THINK WE'VE SEEN HOW
MUCH TELLS ME NOT MUCH AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE HE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO PROVE HIMSELF AND
AT A MINIMUM I WOULD WANT TO
PUT A LOT OF INCENTIVES IN
THERE AND PER GAME ROSTER
PAY HIM UNLESS HE'S ACTUALLY
ABLE TO SUIT UP AND PLAY WILL